back overseas and to Japan this morning
where protests greeted the official
funeral for ex-prime Minister Shinzo Abe
the ceremony at Tokyo's famous Budokan
Arena included military honors vice
president Kamala Harris led the U.S
delegation to the funeral on a trip that
will also take her to Korea's
demilitarized zone later in the week as
Elizabeth Palmer reports the facts of
Abe's assassination nearly three months
ago overshadowed the nation's final
goodbye
[Music]
it is into the few General Hall
dominated by a giant portrait of Japan's
longest serving prime minister more than
4 000 dignitaries and guests paid their
respects to a man who was proud of his
friendship with successive U.S
presidents today vice president Kamala
Harris was in attendance on behalf of
the American people
shot with a homemade gun
yamagami but as yamagami awaits trial
for murder The Fallout from his crime
has ignited an epic Scandal around the
right-wing unification Church also known
as the Moonies yamagami told police he
killed Shinzo Abe for his political
links to the unification church and it
was this 2021 video of Abe speaking to
and praising the group that set him off
the Moonies are best known everywhere
for elaborate Mass weddings but they
also pressure members to make lavish
donations and that says yamagami is what
happened to his mother she gave them so
much money she bankrupted the family now
the church is under intense and hostile
media scrutiny though it says it later
returned about half the money but in
this tabloid spread yamagami supporters
call his action Revenge
in Tokyo demonstrators protested against
the cost of Abby's funeral but people
are also outraged by what they've
learned about how the unification Church
gets money from the vulnerable in
donations or for merchandise like twenty
thousand dollars for this urn and thirty
thousand for a book of the founders
teachings for the church itself it will
be very bad Jeff Hall lectures in
Japanese politics and culture the church
will forever be tarred by this Scandal
and it will have a lot of trouble
getting new recruits in Japan so in a
way tatsuya yamagami got what he wanted
but in his determination to hurt the
church he killed one of the most
powerful significant leaders of modern
Japan for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth
Palmer in Tokyo